[Music]
the tongue of a western diamondback
rattlesnake cautiously tastes the air
[Music]
she flicks airborne particles against
the roof of her mouth to be analyzed
[Music]
sorting out potential food
from potential threat
this other icon of the old west
and he's hungry himself
the roadrunner is a tough old bird
you have to be when the slithering lunch
you've got your eye on could kill you
the queen of rattlers the western
diamondback is a recipe for deadly
indigestion
she's venomous enough to kill a human
but she's missing something in this
looming face-off
legs
[Music]
the roadrunner has got serious legs
and he knows how to use them
[Music]
native americans revered the roadrunner
for its speed strength and especially
its courage
[Music]
the bird circles spiraling in on its
target
but the snake's not going down without a
fight
[Music]
the plan is to grab the snake behind her
head and bash the poor girl's skull in
[Music]
in this face-off
guts versus venom
is a draw
and our snake gets away with her life
[Music]
[Music]
you